hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn
today we will learn about the most
trending topic in the current world of
android development
that's the kotlin versus java now before
we begin
how about you subscribe to the simply
learns youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
to never miss an update on the trending
technologies in the current it industry
also if you are interested in learning
more about the latest programming
languages
then please visit the simply learn
official website
where you can learn more about the
latest languages and their trends in the
current iit industry
now without any further due let us
quickly dive into our agenda
first we will have a briefing about the
java programming language
that will enlighten us about its
definition features
and some of the major projects built
using java
similarly we will have an introduction
with kotlin as well after we get
good introduction related to both these
programming languages
we will then get to learn about java's
edge over kotlin
where we will understand the
capabilities of java which make it
powerful enough to outline the issues
that kotlin could not
similarly we will also have a discussion
about the capabilities of kotlin
that give it a cut through competition
to java in some serious performance
sectors
later we will enter into our main topic
for today's discussion
that is the kotlin versus java where we
will learn the key differences between
the both
next we will learn why exactly google
had to switch to kotlin
for its android operating system and
finally
we will wind up the session by
understanding if it's really the end
time for java
or is kotlin really capable of replacing
java
and which language should you preferably
choose for your future
i hope i am clear with my agenda now let
us quickly begin with our first topic
that is what is java
putting it straight forward java is a
general purpose programming language
that is class based object
object-oriented and designed to have
as few implementation dependencies as
possible
java is being the most powerful language
since day one
and is capable of supporting the
development of multiple software
applications
operating systems and even new
programming languages
the reason for its outstanding superior
performance is its features
the first one among its features are
high portability
the compiler in java is written in an cc
with a clean portable boundary
which is none other than posix subset
having a neutral architecture
and no implementation dependent aspects
of the specification
makes java the most portable language
next comes the support for android from
its official release
23rd september 2008 java was the one
used to design develop and deploy the
linux based operating system worldwide
as the android mobile operating system
android uses most of the java classes
and libraries for its use
next is the most powerful yet hidden
most of the time kind of feature of java
which is java's virtual machine many
call it the jvm as an abbreviation
and jvm is responsible for providing
java its platform independent nature
which makes it most capable and superior
programming languages
to run on any computing device
regardless of the operating system
platform
the device is running on the most
important feature that is responsible
for choosing java by
most learners and professionals is its
simplicity and
readability java is designed to be easy
to learn
and if you learn the basic concepts of
object-oriented programming
it will be easier to master
next important feature is the java
security
java security enables the development of
virus-free tamper-free systems
authentication techniques are based on
public key encryption
next with java's multi-threaded feature
it is possible to write programs that
can perform
many tasks simultaneously this design
feature allows the developers to
construct
interactive applications that can run
smoothly
java's bytecode is translated on the run
to native machine instructions
and not stored anywhere the development
process is
more rapid and analytical since the
linking is an incremental and
lightweight process
with the use of just-in-time compilers
java enables
high performance so this brings us to a
question
who is using java currently and which
platforms are developed using it
well the list could never end yet i
could mention some of the major
platforms
applications like uber spotify instagram
google netflix and airbnb are being
developed under
news of java programming language now
let us take a step further and get
started with copeland
so what is kotlin
released on february 16 2016
by jetbrains kotlin is a statically
typed open source programming language
that runs on jvm and an official
language for developing
android applications kotlin basically
gets broken down into java byte code for
compilation
and this caught the attention of many
android developers
not only this but there is also a quite
a few interesting features
that kotlin can support let's get going
with the features
in many cases one does not need to use
explicit type casting operators in
kotlin
because the compiler tracks the east
checks and explicit cache for immutable
values and
inserts cast automatically wherever they
are needed
kotlin proved that it is highly
interoperable as it is compatible with
most of the java libraries and gets
transformed
into java bytecode this allowed
developers not to face any troubles
while working with java based projects
kotlin is an open source project
under the apache 2.0 license that makes
it available on github
and is open for community and its
support as well
kotlin is developed by one of the major
pioneers in software and
ide development which is none other than
the jetbrains
this makes it trustworthy and secure as
it has constant
r d and community support from its giant
the statically typed nature of the
programming language makes it less prone
to errors
as they get rectified most of the time
during the compilation stage itself
last but not the least kotlin is
considered to be highly efficient
due to its concise coding you can say it
reduces like
40 to 50 percent of the code that you
usually type in java
and most of it was the type of
boilerplate code
now this brings us to know the popular
applications developed using kotlin
some of the major projects that are
developed using kotlin are
coidon spring telegram evernote gradle
build tool
pinterest etc next in the docket
is java's edge over copeland
the first one is the checked exceptions
java has
checked exceptions while kotlin does not
examination of
small programs leads to the conclusion
that requiring exception specifications
could both enhance developer
productivity
and enhance code quality without them
the developers observed
decreased productivity and little or no
increase in code quality
next is the non-private fields
encapsulation is essential in any
program for achieving a desirable level
of maintainability
by means of encapsulating the
representation of an object
it can be enforced how callers interact
with it
moreover it is possible to change the
representation
without the need to modify callers
provided the public api remains
unchanged non-private fields or
public fields in java are useful in
scenarios
where the colors of the object need to
change accordingly
to its representation it simply means
that such fields expose the
representation
of the object to the callers kotlin
doesn't have
non-private fields the next important
one is
static members and static methods now in
android development
things are moving quickly from java to
kotlin
and one of the biggest problems that
developers face while migrating from
java to kotlin
is making a static method because in
kotlin
there is nothing such as static yes you
heard it right
kodlin does not have static keyboard
if you're an android developer and you
love making android applications in java
then you must have used static keyword
in your application
to make some static variables and static
methods and so on
static variables belong to a class and
not its
instance the same is with static methods
as well
after static methods and static members
we have issues with
primitive types in kotlin the primitive
data types are most
fundamental types in kotlin all other
types are built on top of the types
and arrays thereof their representation
is very efficient both in terms of
memory and cpu time
as they map two small byte groups that
are directly manipulated
by the cpu and this type of issue is not
faced in
java lastly the support for terinary
operator
java has the ternary operator support
which most of the time helps to decrease
the code length in simple terms
this is not available in kotlin now
without the support of static methods
and ternary operator you might have a
tough time developing
now let us learn the kotlin's edge over
java
one of the most common pitfalls in many
programming languages
including java is that accessing a
member
of a null reference which will result in
a null reference exception
in java this would be equivalent of a
null pointer exception or
npe for short courtlands time system is
aimed to eliminate
the null pointer exception from our code
not only this
the only possibilities of npe may be an
explicit call
to through null pointer exception or the
usage of exclamatory or
not operator next is the separate
interface for readable
and mutable collection the kotlin
standard library offers generic
interfaces
classes and functions for creating
populating and managing collections of
any type the collection interfaces and
related functions are located in
kotlin.collections package the kotlin
standard library provides implementation
for basic collection types
sets lists and maps a pair of interfaces
represent
each collection type a read-only
interface that provides operations for
accessing collection elements
and a mutable interface that extends the
corresponding read-only interface
with write options followed by that we
have the companion objects
if you need to write a function that can
be called without having a class
instance
but needs to access to internals of the
class for example facade method
you can write it as a member of the
object declaration inside
that particular class even more
specifically
if you declare a companion object inside
your class
then you can access its members using
only the class name as a qualifier
next ahead we have the first class
delegation pattern
the delegation pattern has proven to be
a good alternative to implementation of
inheritance and kotlin supports it
natively requirement zero boilerplate
code
a class derived can implement an
interface base by delegating all of its
public members to a specified object
followed by that we have the operator
overloading
kotlin allows us to provide
implementation for a predefined set of
operators on our types
these operators have fixed symbolic
representation like plus
star etc and their precedence
is fixed to implement an operator we
provide the member function
or an extension function with a fixed
name for the corresponding type
that is left hand side type for the
binary operations
and argument types for unary ones
functions that overload operators
need to be marked with the operator
modifier finally
we have the primary constructors
a class in kotlin can have a primary
constructor and
one or more secondary constructors the
primary constructor is a part of the
class header
it goes after the class name and
optional type parameter
and if the constructor does not have any
annotations or
visibility modifiers then the
constructor keyword can be omitted
the bottom line is kotlin made the use
of constructors
more simplified with this let us move
ahead into the next topic
which is the kotlin versus java
the first parameter that we will be
discussing is the speed
java compilation time is 15 to 20
percent faster than kotlin compilation
time
but the perspective of the incremental
build compilation
kotlin will also take the same
compilation time as
java
next is the null pointer exception in
case
if you intentionally declare a null
value then the cochlear code will be
collapsed
while compilation whereas on the other
hand in java the null pointer exception
is the biggest nightmare for java
programmers
after this we have the extension
functions
kotlin provides developers the ability
to extend existing classes
with new functionality we can create
extent functions by prefixing the name
of the class to the name of the new
function
while on the other hand in java if we
want to extend the functionality of the
existing class
then we need to create a new class and
inherit the parent class
so extension functions are not available
in java
the next major difference is the casting
in kotlin the smartcast will handle
these casting checks
with keyword ease checks this will check
for immutable values and perform
implicit casting while on the other hand
in java
we need to check the type of the
variables and cast according to the
operation
in other words it is completely manual
next ahead we have the checked
exceptions
in kotlin we don't have checked
exceptions so
developers don't need to declare or
catch the exceptions
which have advantages and disadvantages
while on the other hand in java we have
checked exception support
which makes the developers declare and
catch exception which ultimately leads
to robust code
with good error handling later
we have the language type kotlin is a
mix of procedural and
functional programming language which
consists of many useful methods
such as lambda operator overloading
higher order function
and lazy evaluation etc while on the
other hand
java does not have the functional
programming support till java 8
but while developing android application
it support
only subset of java 8 features
then we have the data types in kotlin we
don't need to specify the data type for
each variable
explicitly as the assignment will be
taken care by kotlin internally
while on the other hand in java we need
to specify the type of each variable
explicitly
while the declaration stage and lastly
the getter and set of methods in kodlin
if we need to have classes
which needs to hold data we can declare
a class with keyword data
in class definition then the compiler
will take care of all this work such as
creating constructors getters etc
etc while on the other hand in java
suppose we need to have a class
which need to hold the data but nothing
else for this we need to define
constructors
variables to store data getter and setup
methods hash code string
etc functions which is completely manual
with this we shall now move into our
next topic where we will discuss about
the google switch to kotlin
there were several reasons behind the
incident where google had to switch from
java
to kotlin for its android operating
system
but let us discuss some of the important
ones
first android needed something more
precise and concise
in order to express new ideas and
execute them
accurately kotlin's modern language
features allows you to focus on
expressing your ideas
and write less boilerplate code next
is to achieve safer and more reliable
coding platform
for instance let us consider the null
pointer exception
kotlin introduced a way to improve your
app quality
with add nullable and add non-null baked
into its
type system kotlin helps to avoid
costly null pointer exceptions followed
by that
we have the interoperability google had
to switch from java one or the other day
it is obvious that the latest technology
may become obsolete one or the other day
similarly
java so android was looking for one such
platform
which could support its empire kotlin is
100
interoperable with its java programming
language
so you can have your project shifted to
kotlin with
least effort next is the efficiency
kotlin asynchronous programming making
most common tasks like network
calls database updates the simplest and
performant
last but most importantly google had to
make this move as oracle
acquired java and commercialized it
google had to get rid of java sooner or
later since the time oracle took control
of java
and observed google's use of java api in
android it has been bombarding google
the lawsuit was about the commercial use
of java api oracle goes for
appeal against google and oracle one
so google had to switch from java to
another programming language
now comes the question of the session
can kotlin really replace java
the answer is obviously a big no
kotlin was built to incorporate with
java kotlin was just a fix to java's
tedious problems in android development
but not to replace java as a whole
so you might have many questions right
now about everything
one common question is which programming
language
should you choose so if you are the one
who is going to start your career with
the following technology such as
mobile applications server-side and
client-side applications
data science etc then having a sound
knowledge of kotlin
would be an added advantage so on the
other hand when it comes to java
strictly anything you want to do needs
java so if you are thinking to begin
your career with these fields mentioned
below
that are java web applications
scientific applications
software tools big data etc then i
suggest you go with
java now with this we come to an end of
this session on kotlin versus java
i hope this session was helpful if you
have any queries based on this tutorial
or any questions related to java or
kotlin
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below and we will
have your questions answered by our
experts
as soon as possible it's ravi signing
off and don't forget to get subscribed
to our channel
and hit the bell icon to receive
important updates on the trending
technologies
thank you until next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here